Salut les Epicurieuses et les Epicurieux!
Ah bah non, il n'y a plus de batterie,
je suis sûr que ça vous arrive
et ce n'est pas à cause du froid.
Allez, on va se mettre au chaud.
Je vais vous expliquer
comment elles fonctionnent
et comment les faire durer plus longtemps.
C'est vraiment un plat.
Il fait meilleur ici et je vais
en profiter pour faire le plein.
Alors, le principe de base
de fonctionnement de nos batteries
n'a rien de nouveau.
On provoque
une réaction chimique entre deux métaux
pour créer un courant électrique.
On doit ce procédé à Alessandro Volta,
un scientifique italien
qui a assemblé la première pile en 1800.
Son invention a été baptisée ainsi
parce qu'il s'agissait d'un empilement,
comme ici, de rondelles de cuivre
et de rondelles de zinc séparées
par des tampons imbibés d'eau salée.
Le zinc est un métal
qui a tendance à perdre des électrons,
alors que le cuivre est un métal
qui lui a tendance à gagner des électrons.
Ils forment des ions, c'est à dire des atomes
qui portent des charges électriques.
L'eau salée est un électrolytes,
un liquide dans lequel peuvent
circuler ces yeux quand on relie
les deux extrémités de la pile.
Le pôle négatif
et le pôle positif par un fil conducteur
on permet aux électrons de circuler,
du moins vers le plus.
C'est ce qu'on
appelle un courant électrique.
Le problème des piles de première
génération, c'est que le phénomène n'est
pas réversible
quand tout le zinc est oxydé.
La pile
est bonne à jeter, pas n'importe où.
Aujourd'hui,
dans nos batteries de téléphone,
on utilise des ions lithium,
un métal qui a un potentiel réducteur
quatre fois plus important que le zinc .
C'est l'élément chimique
qui partage le plus ces électrons.
Il a bon cœur, ce lithium.
Il a l'autre avantage d'être le métal
le plus léger, ce qui nous permet d'avoir
des téléphones qui pèse aux alentours
de 150 grammes, équipé de batteries
qui fournissent de l'énergie
pendant près de 20 4 h.
Le courant se produit
grâce à la circulation d'ions lithium
entre les deux électrodes au sein
de plusieurs cellules comme celle ci.
On ne parle plus de pile,
mais d'accumulateur parce que cette fois,
la réaction chimique est réversible.
Pendant qu'on utilise la batterie,
les ions lithium migrent vers la cathode,
qui est souvent formée d'un mélange
de lithium et d'autres métaux.
Et quand on branche notre téléphone
pour le recharger, le courant
renvoie les ions lithium vers l'anode
en graphite où ils sont stockés.
Ce passage des ions
d'une électrode à l'autre représente
ce que l'on appelle un cycle de charge
une batterie ne peut supporter
qu'un nombre de cycles limités.
Avec les technologies actuelles,
on est au minimum à 2000
charge, soit une durée de vie
d'environ dix ans
en fonction
de l'utilisation de l'appareil.
Il n'est donc pas nécessaire de changer
son téléphone tous les deux ans.
J'ai d'ailleurs fait une vidéo à ce sujet
dans laquelle j'explique
également comment nos téléphones portables
sont recyclés.
Elle se trouve ici, dans le petit.
L'usure est due à plusieurs raisons.
Au fur et à mesure des charges
et des décharges, des dépôts se forment
à l'intérieur de la batterie
et les électrodes se déforment.
Les ions lithium s'échangent
donc de moins en moins bien
et ils finissent par ne plus circuler
du tout.
La manière dont nous utilisons
nos téléphones
peut accélérer cette dégradation.
Il y a deux phases pendant lesquelles
la batterie se détériore le plus
quand la charge est comprise
entre 0 et 20%
et quand elle est comprise
entre 80 et 100%.
Premiers conseils, donc, pour prolonger
la durée de vos batteries.
Faire en sorte que la charge
soit le plus souvent comprise
entre 20 et 80%,
ce qui correspond
à la zone de fonctionnement optimale.
Très concrètement,
n'attendez pas qu'elle soit
complètement vide pour la recharger
et à l'inverse, ne laissez pas
votre téléphone branché en permanence.
Évitez de le laisser branché
toute la nuit, par exemple.
C'est plus facile à dire
qu'à faire s'il faut se relever
en pleine nuit
pour débrancher son téléphone.
Je sais aller.
Autre conseil
privilégiez les chargeurs du fabricant.
Ils coupent automatiquement le courant
quand la batterie est chargée à 100%.
On l'a dit,
une batterie produit de l'électricité
grâce à une réaction chimique.
Et comme beaucoup de réactions chimiques,
elle est influencée par la température.
Quand il fait très froid,
la batterie est un peu comme nous.
Elle est engourdi.
Les ions lithium circulent de plus en plus
lentement entre les électrodes.
Donc, contrairement à ce
qu'on entend souvent,
le froid ne décharge pas la batterie
plus vite
puisque les ions ne circulent plus
vers la cathode.
Et je ne suis pas fou.
J'ai vu la jauge diminuer sous mes yeux.
Non, tu n'es pas fou.
Le froid ralentit
parfois tellement la circulation
des ions dans la batterie que celle ci
ne produit plus assez de courant.
Le téléphone pense
que la batterie est à plat
alors qu'elle est juste en train
d'hiberner.
C'est un malentendu.
Par conséquent,
pas besoin de la brancher tout de suite.
Attendez que le téléphone se réchauffe
un peu à température ambiante
pour voir si la jauge remonte.
Pour faire durer la batterie
plus longtemps,
j'ai fait une petite bouillotte
ou à la très mauvaise idée.
Elle craint aussi le chaud.
La chaleur accélère la réaction chimique
qui a lieu dans la batterie.
Elle peut aussi déformer
les électrodes de façon irréversible.
Tout cela empêche les ions de se fixer
correctement
et diminue
la capacité de stockage d'énergie.
une surchauffe trop importante
peut même entraîner
des réactions chimiques qui peuvent aller
jusqu'à l'explosion de la batterie.
Tu aurais pu dire à vendre
les batteries lithium ion
sont dans le commerce depuis 1991
et la technologie n'a cessé de s'améliorer
grâce aux recherches
sur les nouveaux matériaux donnés
pendant les 20 dernières années.
Leur capacité a doublé.
Bon, en même temps,
la consommation électrique
de nos smartphones
augmente tout aussi vite.
Alors, sur quelles pistes travaillent
les chercheurs et les ingénieurs
pour améliorer leur capacité
et leur durée de vie?
Eh bien, ils essaient de changer
les ingrédients en remplaçant
l'électrolyte liquide par des solides,
qui résisteraint mieux à la chaleur
ou en remplaçant le lithium par du sodium.
Mais bon, pour le moment,
ils n'ont pas encore trouvé
la bonne recette pour que nos batteries
durent plus longtemps dans la journée.
Les ingénieurs essaient d'intégrer
des panneaux solaires dans les écrans
des téléphones ou de mini
générateurs capables de transformer
les mouvements du téléphone
en électricité.
Tu veux dire qu'il
va se recharger en bougeant?
un jour, peut être, pendant
que mon téléphone finit de se charger.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu, n'hésitez
pas à liker et à vous abonner à la chaîne.
Ah, c'est bon, je suis rechargé
ma batterie et recharger à 80%.
Je vais pouvoir repartir à l'aventure,
aller à dans deux semaines.
Les épicuriens et les épicuriens.
Alors
pourquoi la fondue fait, elle
défile et répond.
Et encore plus de questions
dans ce petit livre
réalisé en partenariat avec Natan.
Vous y retrouverez également un quiz et un
test pour savoir quel fromage vous êtes.
Personnellement, je sais Roquefort.
Avis aux fondu
de lecture, le lien est ici.